hello Fabiana you are one of the most
you have one of the most hectic
schedules among top chess players how do
you keep up your energy and how do you
not burn out after playing tournament
after tournament overseas and here I'm
pretty used to it by now I've been very
active on the scene for the last few
years and I do try to make time in
between tournaments to rest and recover
my energy so before this I I had a
relatively long break a few weeks and I
think it was more than enough time to
recover I would say a lot of people
think that a couple of weeks or a few
weeks is not a long time to recover but
you seem to have no problem with it yeah
I am fine the motivation and energy to
keep playing tournaments but maybe it's
a matter of just being used to it
because I've always been pretty active
I've always accepted a lot of
invitations and and taken less time than
other players in between tournaments now
very recently the u.s. of course won
gold in Baku historic achievement for
sure has that changed the dynamic
between some of the top American players
or not at all I when we're playing the
tournament I think we're good teammates
and we're trying our best to to score
good result and we managed to to score
an excellent one but in between
tournaments we're still trying to to
outperform each other and so I've I
think it's just normal that after the
Olympiad I'm playing in car over here
and I will try to to score ahead of him
I beat him